the newest display the bellagio
conservatory is
up and spreading love rocky theos is
there live to tell us the story behind
the design and it looks like a nice
place just to do some
zen and relax
yes that is the perfect introduction to
what i have to talk about kirsten
because
we're talking about the story of the
conservatory new display
and what you first hear is the music
and i want to shout out leslie because
she did the playlist here so
what are people hearing when they come
through this they're hearing a mix of
relaxation some some tunes to get them
to reflect but then also to ultimately
reinvigorate
as you're going through the gardens and
experiencing and
feeling the zen it is beautiful i i you
know
feel free to email me the playlist later
we'll talk about that
okay but now i want you to feel like
you're here at the bellagio conservatory
and who better to make you feel that way
is ed because he designed this place
so walk us through that paint the
picture so this is our season of love
and we're telling the story
through the tenacity and determination
of the strong oxier
balancing on this delicate bridge which
is the lifestyle we want to return to
when this whole pandemic is over
we look through into the north bed and
that's a celebration of family and
travel we're all dying to travel
again soon someday and this is the
temple of the six banyan trees which is
where children are taken
to be blessed before adoption which is
kind of amazing tribute to family and
culture
over here on the south bed is a tribute
to learning
and the love of nature and up above we
see the jade
jade is said to be precious
and priceless gold is is precious and
jade is priceless
so this is kind of so it's all
subliminal messages that we're
saying instead of being so literal we're
telling
the things through basically through
asian folklore the stories through asian
folklore
you interpret it for yourself which
brings us to our spectacular
west bed which is one of my favorite
things that i've designed in the past
six years here this is my favorite two
head and this
is our interpretation of a very
well-known asian love story about the
jade emperor's daughter
and the oxhurt so this is the only time
we would ever tell this is is
during the season of the the year of the
ox and this is a
story where the jade emperor's daughter
fell in love with the oxford
and they were separated and a bridge of
magpies which forms the milky way
arched once a year and brought them back
together and they sat on the lovers
bunch
so this is a story that we're telling
during the east meets west is that we're
telling the story during the traditional
western valentine's day
this is incredible ed once again you
have outdone yourself
this has got to be my favorite display
you've done so far and so thank you
to you and the team for bringing so much
life so much beauty to the strip every
time every season
thank you it's my pleasure and look it's
turning it's turning
into evening now and you're getting a
whole nother herd another take on the
on the environment that we that we had
during the day too so it's very special
to come down in the evening and see it
yes you guys have to come down
we're here till march 6th you can enjoy
the season
of love that's something we all need
right i'll send it back to you guys in
studio